[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii we will talk about the polish jewish
songs that were sung by peret's h
a holocaust survivor born in 1927
in warsaw when war broke out he was a
little boy
parrots used to sing in the streets of
his home city to earn
a living and shared several songs in his
1993
fortunate video archive testimony songs
of the survivors
like parrots are of truly special value
as they shed a unique light on the
polish and more specifically
warsaw music culture on the interwar and
world war
ii periods some of the texts like this
one in parity's testimony are not to be
found
in any known sources today pochongo
yestwok
crowded train is one of at least two
polish renditions of the popular mexican
coppola
song sielita lindo just like val's
francois
that we discussed in the first episode
this is the song that paris h
sang in the courtyards of warsaw along
with many other children
like himself as well as local street
bands
which would have been lost to history if
not for the testimony of parrot's age
refers to the depression and smuggling
of rosaries
in the pre-war warsaw in post-war
poland the song gained newfound
popularity
thanks in part to leonard buchkovsky
1946 movie zakazane piosenki
forbidden songs the new version although
similar to the pre-war version
sung by parrots referred to the war
terrazie esteboina
tengem it is war now those who sell
live decades later in 1982
the polish cielito lindo came back to
life with a new lyrics
yet again in the wake of the military
coup d'etat
is
yes
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is hmm
crowded train it is a very special
song which help people might say living
even survive but
the origin of this song is not in polish
language
and in not in polish culture the origins
comes to
back to latin america
mexico where it was called
chilita lindo and it was a
folk song belonging to the cop
and performed by
mariachi wandering bands during that
time and it was popularized
by the composer quirino
in late 19th century he used this
melody for his composition
the the wrestler and from that time it
became enormously popular
in mexico in different spanish culture
diasporas
in the world but very soon also
in other cultures as well so
the song was performed by such famous
singers
like placido domingo luciano pavarotti
in poland by famous singers
violeta villas or maria
who performed it under the title
long-living double dancing party which
became a very popular
song during communist time in poland
but it came to poland
in the 30s of last century
via berlin
and it was sung by a
famous chilean singer
at that time
rosita serrano who came
to berlin singing
it she was called julian
nightingale very famous singer and that
that was uh the way how how it came from
the
berlin to pre-war were so it was time of
depression
a time of economical crisis so
the lyrics to this song
were in polish were about
smuggling groceries
in trains or trams in warsaw
and this version of the song was
forgotten
in in poland and i think thanks to the
performance
by mr parrots in that recording
we still can have this lyric since his
first version of polish
presence of of this song at
that time we may call this type of songs
when we called
which means that there is a substitution
of one text to the another
without any substantial change in music
so we keep
the melody and change the lyrics
according to circumstances
historical political cultural
circumstances
so when war came
towards so uh to poland in
1939 the lyrics
changed and it was
mostly about the war kerashi's voice
it is war now who sells
leaves and
it was sang by the people on the streets
who from one side like mr parrots
wanted to survive to make their living
from the other hand it was sang
by people who were engaged in
underground movement
so it was still about
smuggling but not necessarily groceries
also weapons and illegal literature as
well
and because of that it was
sometimes very dangerous to be a singer
of that songs
because many of them belong to the
underground
movement and took part in actions again
against germans during the occupation
time so we started to call
that songs forbidden songs and this is a
title
of a famous movie which was
icing the first feature movie after the
war in poland
created in 1947
by the film director a film director
leonard buchkowski who established his
career before the war as director of
famous war movies
with big budget
and and he cooperated
after the war with ludwig starsky for
screenwriting who was an author of
screen
writing for this movie ludwig starsky
was the father of a famous set designer
film
designer alan starsky who worked for
many years with sanjivada
and he was also awarded by
academy award for schindler
schindler's list in 1994
so they both buchkovsky star
estarski decided to make a song
a hero of this film
so it is a plot of course around
it about different underground
activities in
in in warsaw during the occupation
but the main hero of this movie
is a song the forgotten songs and among
them the crowded train
the communist authorities were not
satisfied with
the first version of this movie it was
not enough
for them politically engaged on the
soviet
uh side and not enough
underlying the cruelty of
german soldiers so
after two years they made a second
version
of of this movie and
you know it it it became a very
a very famous
film which popular popularizes
song crowded train again
but this is not end of the story
and this song has long living
in fact when we in poland had a
so-called martial law uh implemented by
general
jaroszewski in december
13 1981
uh mostly people in poland felt that
there is another type of occupation that
the war came back it was a war we see in
our society
but it was a good ground a new context
for
for such songs from the world time
and again crowded train became
very popular at that time under
of course a new title
and with new lyrics now about
green crow jealous verona verona was in
the aberration
of government name
you know in this new regime
circumstances
so it was a new living for
that song and i wish
that it will be not the end
of the story uh i wish
that this song will survive
in our cultural memory in archives
and that this song will influence
new productions and performings
but my hope is that never again
in connection with new wars in the
future let's keep it
for the peace time
[Music]
you